welcome to the 2011 lecture series on
business in the environment I'm read
lips at the Associate Director of the
industrial environmental management
program and chair of the lecture series
here at the school of Forestry and
environmental studies through this
lecture series started in 1991 we seek
to bring corporate executives and others
to the Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies to talk about
topics of current interest and in many
cases cutting edge developments in
environmental management policy and
science we value the additional
perspective that business people bring
to our discussions at the yell
environment school and the opportunity
to have students and faculty meet them
and for them to meet us in the past
we've explored such topics as the
emerging role of lifecycle oriented
management and product take back the
environmental impact of the service
industries and green domestic markets in
developing countries the IEM program the
sponsor of the series is a research and
teaching unit within yells environment
school under its laws under auspices is
a track in the master's program in this
lecture series and the editorship of the
Journal of industrial ecology be sure to
grab some brochures at the back the
lecture series is supported by a small
endowment the Joel AmeriCorps ahora fund
Joel was a graduate of the environment
school and the school of management in
1991 you went to work for conrail and
was active in the global environmental
management initiative he was very bright
very committed and very energetic
believer in the importance of greening
corporate practice when he died eighteen
years ago conrail his colleagues family
and friends established a memorial to
honor him his parents ask that the funds
be used to support this series because
they think it captures well his
commitment to dialogue about business in
the environment this year I'm pleased to
announce that we have a very special
lecture series with the support from
nestle waters north america the theme is
producers packaging and public policy
the lecture series explores the topic of
extended producer responsibility also
known as EPR and packaging EPR is a
policy
oh gee that makes producers responsible
for their products when they become
waste the goal of the lecture series
this year is to explore the advantages
and disadvantages of the application of
epr to packaging waste and municipal
solid waste more generally in the u.s.
nestle waters north america the market
leader in bottled water in North America
and a division of Nestle SA the global
food and beverage company is seeking to
significantly improve the recycling of
beverage containers and all recyclable
packaging materials as part of that
effort they're supporting discussion and
debate over the feasibility and
effectiveness of epr in the US and we
have a representative here Mike Washburn
from nestle waters Keep America
Beautiful a US nonprofit organization
promoting litter and waste reduction and
the resource recovery forum a uk-based
international nonprofit network of
organizations interested in sustainable
waste management are assisting and
publicizing the lecture series on EP are
the first talk in our series is by dr.
Carol lavender law a leading researcher
on the topic of marine plastic debris
dr. laws talk on plastic marine debris
is one of several in this year series
that will set the context for debates
over public policy towards plastic pop
plastic packaging plastic debris in
marine environments often call garbage
patches is a growing concern that is
raising questions about materials choice
and waste management for packaging and
other products a research oceanographer
with se a doctor law received her
undergraduate training in mathematics
from Duke University and a doctorate
from the Scripps Institution of
Oceanography in 2001's EA is an
educational institution dedicated to
exploration understanding and
stewardship of the oceans that
specializes in taking college students
to the deep ocean on a traditional
sailing vessel to learn about the sea as
part of its se a semester program s EA
has been collecting data on plastic
marine debris for more than a quarter of
a century generating a unique and
powerful data set analysis based on that
data culminated this fall in the
publication of a widely read article in
the journal Science other speakers in
the series in this
this year will address the role of
biodegradability in packaging waste
management the relationship between
materials choice packed and packaging
design on the one hand and waste
infrastructure on the other and the
findings from life cycle assessments of
packaging the history of epr in North
America and the history of US federal
policy towards packaging waste many of
the lectures in the series will take the
form of webinars if you would like to be
notified notified of the various
lectures by email please be sure to sign
up on the list just outside the lecture
hall the lecture by dr. law is being
videotaped and will be available on the
website of the el school of Forestry and
environmental studies also please note
that our class will be held in this room
immediately after the talk so we need to
clear the room promptly thus is it with
it is with considerable pleasure and
anticipation and gratitude for a
incredible drive this morning and that I
turn the podium over to dr. law who will
tell us about the science behind Ocean
garbage patches thanks
okay well thank you very much read for
inviting me to come speak to you today
and thank you all for braving icy
sidewalks roads etc to come here to talk
about trash what I hope you take from
today's talk is an accurate picture of
the problem of marine debris in the
oceans and one that's one based on
scientific study this picture may be at
odds with what you've heard about the
issue of garbage patches in the media
and first and foremost is the misleading
nature of that term which is why it is
italicized and in quotes in the title of
my talk I should say right off the bat
that is not to say that ocean pollution
especially with respect to plastic is
not a real environmental concern but at
the end of the talk you maybe find
yourself wondering what exactly do we
know about this environmental problem
because at this point there really are
far more questions that have that are
remaining than have yet that have yet
been answered so most of the awareness
of this environmental problem has been
focused on what's been called in
particular the great pacific garbage
patch or you may have heard more
recently about the great atlantic
garbage patch patch and i'm sure you're
familiar with this issue how many people
have heard of this phenomenon before
yeah most people in the room I suspect
what you have heard is that there is
some sort of floating landfill in the
ocean that is twice the size of Texas or
France or the united states that there
is more plastic than plankton floating
around in the ocean and if you do a
Google Images search you'll find
pictures like these floating around the
web plastic very thick piles of debris
so thick that you could walk on them and
some people are even proposing cleaning
up this debris and building plastic
Island habitats in the middle of the
ocean so you should be very wary these
pictures by the way are also used by
reputable people you see that even Oprah
Winfrey says this is the most shocking
thing I've ever seen but if you actually
look a little bit closely you'll notice
that there are generally no captions
associated with these images and they
are not attributed so they're not
telling you what you're actually looking
at that's not to say these are
photoshopped in
anyway but they may not be the pictures
from the middle of the ocean in fact
they're not these images do perpetuate
common misconceptions of the problem of
plastic waste in the ocean there is no
floating landfill they're typically
aren't even large masses of accumulated
trash or even things that you can see
detect by I most of the the waste that
is floating around the ocean is not even
visible to an observer from the deck of
the ship let alone from aircraft or
satellite so today and instead actually
let's so big X through those pictures
what you would see if you went into the
places that have been dubbed these
garbage patches are images that are more
similar to this this is from the
Sargasso Sea an area of the subtropical
North Atlantic that i'll be spending a
lot of time talking about today and you
see generally speaking very nice i can't
really can you guys see that there ok
flat seas and sort of cloudy skies just
generally ocean now occasionally from
the deck of the ship you might see some
common everyday items float by such as a
boot or a plastic bucket and this is in
fact very shocking especially if you've
spent any amount of time far from land
on a ship this is not a common
occurrence you may also see some lost
fishing gear or some items that you
don't really know what it is but you can
tell that it's some sort of piece of
floating debris but in any case those
are very different images from the slide
I just showed you so what I'm going to
do today is is spend time talking about
the science behind these issues using
the most extensive data set ever
collected in any ocean compiled on
plastic marine debris so to give you a
sense of where we're going today we're
going to spend a little bit of time
talking about the background to this
issue why does this pollution problem
exists in the ocean specifically what is
marine debris and I'm going to spend
some time introducing the plastic debris
dataset collected by sea Education
Association over the past quarter
century and building on that and I put
in parentheses Atlantic because we do
also operate in the Pacific Ocean
although we've only been operating there
for about the past nine years so we have
data from from the Pacific region as
well as the Atlantic although I won't be
talking about that today and then going
to describe the geographical
distribution of this floating desk
floating plastic
bri and use oceanographic data to
explain this distribution from surface
current patterns explaining why it
collects where it does and then finally
I'll be describing trends in the plastic
floating plastic debris from our 22 year
data set and discuss factors that might
help explain the trends that we observe
and that's including sort of estimates
of the source of plastic to the ocean as
well as removal mechanisms away from the
surface of the ocean and then finally
we'll wrap up with with some of the
outstanding research questions so let's
begin with what is marine debris by
definition marine debris is any solid
man-made material that's processed or
manufactured that persists in the marine
environment and the marine environment
includes beaches coastlines marshes and
other wetlands and also the immensely
vast yet infrequently explored open
ocean which tends to suffer from the out
of sight out of mind mentality marine
debris can consist of many different
materials aluminum glass paper any kind
of packaging that we use any kind of
waste that you would find out there it's
estimated loosely estimated that sixty
to eighty percent of marine debris is
composed of plastic and if you look at
some of these images which are
land-based images you can see certainly
that plastic is a large component from
volunteer beach cleanups and associated
standardized surveys of debris conducted
by the ocean conservancy over the past
25 years or so we do have some pretty
good numbers on the type of debris that
collects on beaches but there have been
very few studies of marine debris in the
open ocean itself although in fact the
first observations of floating plastic
in the ocean were made in the early
1970s in the Atlantic Ocean and in the
late 1970s in the Pacific Ocean so it's
not this is not a new phenomenon the
studies in the in the open ocean have
focused on what is collected at the sea
surface and in fact most of what is is
collected at the sea surface is composed
of plastic so why is plastic so
pervasive well as you know plastic is a
synthetic material it's an organic
polymer that is traditionally derived
from petroleum by
properties the bride design rather the
properties of plastic are those you're
familiar with it is lightweight which
means that most but not all plastic
materials are buoyant and seawater they
float plastic is also designed to be
strong meaning it's very difficult to
break apart mechanically it is durable
and while it does experience some amount
of photo degradation by exposure to UV
radiation that weakens the material but
it doesn't actually degrade it so the
plastic itself the polymer is highly
resistant to biodegradation in the
environment and plastic is also
relatively inexpensive to produce and
what this does is create a perception
that the plastic is really a disposable
material so the result is that plastic
is very persistent in the environment
whether it's marine or otherwise in the
ocean the lifetime of plastic is not
known exposure as I said to UV radiation
and also the turbulent energy of the
waves in the surface ocean environment
do act to break down pieces of plastic
into smaller fragments but to the best
of our knowledge and to the best of our
observations thus far that material does
remain plastic down to perhaps the
molecular level the raw material of
plastic products are shown here these
are plastic resin pellets or industrial
resin pellets and in this photograph you
see that these are really millimeters in
size typically spherical or cylindrical
they do come in a variety of colors many
are sort of white or off-white but
you'll see other colors of these
materials and these are made of virgin
plastic resins so there are a number of
different materials if you look at your
water bottle for instance you'll see on
the bottom there's a code that has a
little number inside and this in this
case this has a number one that means
it's pets that's the type of plastic
material it's made of so any of these
consumer products start out as these
resin pellets which are then shipped to
manufacturers of those consumer products
and formed into the items that we use
every day so just to set the scene let's
talk a little bit about the impacts of
plastic in the marine environment so
there are a number of known
environmental
acts and I'm sure you'll be familiar
with many of these especially the issue
of entanglement you see pictures like
this on the web and they're very
disturbing images entanglement is mostly
an issue for very large sort of
discarded fishing gear in particular
very large items of debris that get
wrapped around the particular types of
animals like seals and sea lions and
turtles the type of debris I'm going to
talk about today is generally not
associated with entanglement ingestion
we know that that plastic debris is
ingested by Marie of everything from
marine mammals and turtles down to see
birds and fish and what I'm showing here
are some images of laysan albatross that
were taken from Korea toll in the
Northwest Hawaiian Islands you see here
a mother albatross feeding its chick and
then nearby another albatross chick that
has died and this the contents of the
stomach of the fish of the bird rather
are shown on this in this picture and
although you can't really see is it
possible to dim the lights in the front
a little bit maybe to help with the
images I guess our person left thank you
in any case what you can see here is
there's actually a huge amount of
plastic in fact the stomach contents of
that bird Wade thank you very much
weighed about 370 grams and 270 grams of
that were plastic and you can even see
items that you recognize like cigarette
lighters here so that that brings about
cartoons like this and maybe you've also
seen images from photographer Chris
Jordan who went to Midway Island and
took just Institute photographs just
went and didn't disturb bird carcasses
at all but took photographs like this
one where you can see again bottle caps
and lighters it I encourage you to visit
that site it's really startling so we
know ingestion is an issue especially
for larger organisms but we also know
that smaller organisms even down to the
planktonic level or in invertebrates
will ingest plastic obviously that is
probably not good for them okay organic
pollutants we know that particular types
of plastic resins can
sort of sponges in the marine
environment and essentially attract and
bind pollutants that are already present
in the in the ocean water examples are
DDT PCBs and pahs we also know that the
plastic the plastics themselves can
leach other additives into the marine
environment that are also harmful
chemicals persistent organic organic
pollutants that can be carcinogenic or
mutagenic or endocrine disruptors so we
know that also is a negative impact and
then finally floating debris here I show
a piece of lost fishing gear that was
pulled aboard on one of our ships acts
as a concentrator basically creating
micro eco systems so we have when we
pull the board this piece of line we
found barnacles and crabs and all sorts
of organisms that just don't belong out
in the middle of the open ocean so not
only do they sort of attach themselves
to this and travel along on as maybe a
sort of a floating raft but this can act
as a transport mechanism for potentially
invasive species throughout the oceans
so also negative impact now these are
some of the impacts that we do know
occur there are also some that are sort
of big questions right now there's this
issue of what kind of microbes are
growing on plastic debris I'm showing
here an image of a very small fragment
of plastic that was collected on a
cruise last summer and looking under
high power magnification you can see
that there are small phytoplankton
single-celled phytoplankton growing
microbes that are have yet to be
identified and then all of these
secretions are microbial secretions so
we know that the plastic not only is
attracting larger organisms like
barnacles and crabs but also there are
microbial biofilms growing on there that
again we're not sure what the species of
these organisms are we don't know if
they belong in that part of the ocean or
not associated with the persistent
organic pollutants that are accumulating
on those plastic particles is a question
of whether or not if those are ingested
those contaminants can transfer to the
tissues of the organism that that has
eaten the plastic and then taking that a
step further whether those contaminants
are then concentrated up the food web
and potentially ending up in our food
supply and that's there are a lot of
steps in that chain of whether or not
this is a threat to human health but
that certainly is a
possibility and there are people
starting to look at those questions we
do know that in at least one seabird
study some of those toxins were found in
the tissue of the seabird so it's
certainly possible but a huge open
question at this point and lastly nobody
to my knowledge has been even thinking
about what the possible chemical impacts
are if this plastic does degrade or
partially degrades leeches whatever
kinds of components into the marine
system we really have no idea what
that's doing to the chemistry of the
ocean so there are certainly reasons to
be concerned about this problem so you
might ask yourself well if if plastics
are so bad why aren't they banned from
the ocean well they are in fact through
an international regulation called
marpole annex five which was adopted in
1988 it is illegal to dump plastic of
any kind into any part of the ocean so
there are strict guidelines for ships at
sea about where they can dub different
types of garbage and in fact just about
anything else can be dumped into the
ocean but everywhere plastic is banned
so this is a good thing and it's been in
for it's been in play for quite a while
now but there are some issues as you
might imagine it's very difficult to
enforce global ocean wide ban on plastic
dumping so unintentional dumping
persists I've lost plastic bit of
something over the side of ship but I'm
sure intentional dumping still occurs at
sea this also doesn't address inputs
from land and I actually that reminds me
I forgot to talk about the source of
plastic to the ocean so let me just take
a step back where how does the plastic
actually get into the ocean we know that
it gets in from land sources and from
from sources at sea so here I'm focusing
on ships and at sea platforms like oil
platforms for instance we know that
plastic is entering again either
intentionally intentional jumping even
though it's been banned or unintentional
losses from those ships and platforms
plastic is also entering from land and
it's coming from land in a number of
ways through water ways such as rivers
or municipal outflows or sewage outflows
basically all rivers end up in the ocean
we also know that any kind of beach
litter will be washed out to sea once
the incoming tide comes in also debris
can be deposited on the beach in that
way and then finally the wind can carry
debris from land out to sea and if you
think about some of the images
after Hurricane Katrina you know we're
talking large boats also in addition to
your plastic candy wrapper so there are
number of different mechanisms it's not
known what proportion of waste comes
from those sources although you will
hear a lot that eighty percent of the
plastic input into the ocean is coming
from land I have not been able to
actually substantiate that estimate okay
so back to where we were so why this
isn't necessarily helping obviously this
doesn't address those sources of plastic
from land and also plastic in the ocean
persists for decades to centuries or
longer we don't actually know the
lifetime so so we still have plenty of
plastic in the ocean even though you
can't throw it overboard from your your
fishing boat so what do we know about
plastic debris in the ocean well let's
see Education Association faculty and
students have been studying the issue of
plastic marine debris for more than 25
years now and as Reed set s EA is a
non-profit educational institution based
in Woods Hole Massachusetts on Cape Cod
and our primary program r is the sea
semester program which is offered to
undergraduates so undergraduates come to
our campus for six weeks and take
coursework in marine science maritime
literature history and policy and also
practical seamanship and then we take
them out to sea on one of our two tall
sailing ships that is outfitted for
oceanographic research either the core
with Kramer which sails in the Atlantic
and Caribbean or the robert c siemens
with which operates in the north and
south pacific so students when they are
on board the ship for their six-week
research cruises are actually
full-fledged members of the ship's crew
they are handling the sales during the
ship working in the galley to prepare
meals in the engine room and they're
working in the laboratory to collect
oceanographic research for independent
research projects that they have
designed onshore and they carry out that
full research project from conception on
shore to full completion on board the
ship in a 12-week period so this is
really the cornerstone of what we do is
collect state-of-the-art ocean
measurements that are comparable to what
you would find from the you know the
major oceanographic institutions and we
collect that data for student use for
their their independent study projects
so what that means is that each voyage
has a scientific mission that is really
defined by the undergraduates and it
carried out on board those six
cruises so to give you a sense of where
we sail in the area i'm going to be
talking about in terms of the atlantic
this is an image showing you a typical
years worth of cruise tracks of the core
with kramer in the atlantic ocean in the
caribbean sea so North America Central
America South America here's the
Caribbean Sea the ship the cruises are
typically six weeks long as I mentioned
and these crews tracks are annually
repeated so every fall the ship leaves
from Woods Hole sales south and ends up
in st. Croix and then spends the winter
in the Caribbean Sea and the southern
Sargasso Sea which is this portion of
the North Atlantic Ocean here doing
research cruises and then in the spring
we sailed back up north to Woods Hole
and spend the summer sailing around in
the Gulf of Maine region so that is
really one of the problem the critical
factors is that we annually repeat these
crews tracks so we've been able to build
a time series of consistently collected
oceanographic data over the past 25
years in fact 40 years is how long we've
been doing the program but given the
evolution and oceanographic methods we
have certainly a robust 25-year data set
and it's really important to measure to
point out here that these data are
collected by have been collected by more
than 7,000 undergraduate students over
that time period and I think it really
is unprecedented for undergraduates to
be the ones primarily responsible for
such an important baseline data set so
to give you a sense of how the data the
plastic marine debris data are collected
I'm showing you this slide here it is
through a very sophisticated method of
net towing the surface plankton net toes
basically this is a net that is a mirror
across and a half meter high and it has
a mesh of 335 microns that's about a
third of a millimeter so that is the
mesh that's that's towed behind the
mouth there at the end there is a little
collection jar called the cod end jar
and we tow this net alongside the ship
here as you can see from the bird's-eye
view for one point eight kilometers it's
one nautical mile at a ship speed of two
knots so more or less we tow this net
along side of the ship for approximately
30 minutes if i can get a mouse there we
go just to give you a sense of what it's
like being on the ship
Oh start already there we go I do have a
little movie here okay so there is no
sound this is the the ship sailing in
the in the Sargasso Sea and we're
lowering this boom which is what we
attach the net to to give you a sense of
the size of the net here you go there
are the people handling it one of the
benefits of this deployment is that is
very easy for students to learn how to
do on their own very quickly there's no
winches involved no heavy machinery it's
very difficult to get hurt here's the
the mouth view of the net as it's towing
along the ocean surface there and you
see that the net is towed half in and
half out of the ocean so the idea is
that we're really sampling less than the
upper half metre of the ocean them truly
measuring the sea surface we bring the
net back on board we unscrew that cod
end jar and dump the contents into a
bucket you'll see that that they're
pulling out something that looks like a
piece of plastic sheeting there's also
some Sargassum weed in the net we dump
that that net contents into a bucket and
then the students spend do the real hard
work here and spend time with the
contents pour it into a sieve literally
picking out pieces of plastic and we're
when we get into the heart of the area
where it's collecting this is a very
tedious job to give you a sense of what
these samples look like I'm showing you
a couple images here collected in the
North Atlantic and this is collected in
the North Pacific to give you to show
you that they're really very similar
samples in either ocean this is that
sieve that we just looked at in the
previous picture at a pair of tweezers
and all these white flick bits that you
see and blue colored pieces this is all
plastic this is what those the typical
piece of plastic marine debris looks
like and on the right hand side here you
see this is actually a petri dish sized
sample and in fact in that I think I
forgot to write it down in this sample I
think there's something like 250 pieces
of plastic and that is a lot of plastic
compared to other parts of the ocean
that I'll show you later really have
zero so to describe these pieces they're
really fragments from one's larger items
they're irregularly shaped they're often
weathered maybe with
edges or perhaps faded from the Sun they
are various colors and in general we
can't tell what type of object these
fragments originated from we can't tell
whether it came from you know a water
bottle or a plastic bag we also can't
tell whether it came from New York City
or France or some other part of the
ocean so we really don't know in their
histories remain a mystery the
exceptions to that are fragments of
polypropylene line which we know are
fishing most likely fishing line and we
also do see those plastic pellets that I
mentioned in the beginning those
industrial produce resin pellets those
are easily distinguishable so part of
what we did was look at a subset of
these samples to try to understand in a
broad sense with the physical
characteristics of this debris floating
out in the ocean are and it's the bottom
line is it's small and it floats so we
looked at over 700 pieces of fragments
collected in the Atlantic Ocean over a
period of about 15 years and we found
that eighty eight percent of pieces are
less than a centimeter in size so that's
smaller than your pinky fingernail they
also more than ninety five percent
weighed less than point 05 grams at ways
that means it weighs less than a staple
so we're talking about very small bits
of plastic we also know that the plastic
floats and the way we did that was we
actually measure the material density of
those pieces and so what's shown here is
a histogram of density from samples
collected in the open ocean and then
samples collected on a beach near our
campus on Cape Cod so this is density
increasing as you go to the right what
you see in the middle here of these bars
are indicating the known manufacturers
density ranges of common plastic
materials like polypropylene the
polyethylenes polystyrene PVC and pet so
hopefully what you see is 0 and then
sorry this dashed line here is telling
you what the density typical density of
surface seawater is for comparison so if
you look at the beach histogram you'll
notice that there is certainly is a
large proportion of low-density material
but we really see material filling the
entire range here of known plastic
material densities whereas in the open
ocean we have very very few samples that
were denser than
the density of surface seawater and in
fact when we looked at those a little
more closely we realize most of them
were chips of paint from the hull of the
ship so the net kind of bangs into the
ship that's a fairly common occurrence
so we know that that the the plastic
we're collecting floats which makes
sense that's why we're collecting it at
the sea surface but we can also
determine that the materials from this
and also we did a further elemental
analysis for carbon nitrogen and
hydrogen again we're able to compare two
known values for these plastic resins
and we were able to say that yes indeed
what we're collecting are the
polyethylene HDPE and LD PE and
polypropylene what we're not collecting
includes pet which is your common water
bottle so that's not to say that that
these materials pet and PVC and the the
solid polystyrene are not in the ocean
it means they are not floating at the
surface of the ocean so we don't have
any measurements of we don't really know
where those materials end up or how much
is in the ocean okay so let's go to the
question of where is this plastic in the
ocean how is it distributed in the North
Atlantic so what I'm showing you here is
a map of the entire data set which
includes more than 6,100 surface net
toes collected over that twenty two year
period so to orient you again North
America South America here's the
Caribbean Sea in here and each symbol
represents the location of one plankton
net toe and it is shaded according to
the concentration of plastic that we
measured in the net so what I should say
is that the way that we compute
concentration students pick out
individual pieces of plastic and they're
counted and carefully recorded and then
we divide that number by the width of
ocean basically the area of ocean that
we've sampled so the area of ocean is a
one meter wide net towed for almost two
kilometers and to put that into everyday
terms we filter approximately 200
bathtub I sorry 2,000 bathtubs worth of
water in one net tow so that's a lot of
water but again when you know sort of
looking at the vast expanse of the ocean
it's it's actually a very small piece of
ocean so when you divide by that area
you end up with plastic pieces per
kilometer squared and that's what these
numbers are showing you here so Blues
are zero plastic pieces are the dark
blues and then low number concentrations
here high concentrations are the warm
colors and then the black stars that you
see here are the highest concentrations
more than 200,000 plastic pieces per
kilometer squared so first let me say
that in total more than 64,000 pieces of
plastic were pulled out of the Nets over
this time period sixty-two percent of
all of the toes that you see in this
figure contained plastic and another
thing I should point out is that the way
this figure was constructed was by
plotting the low concentrations first so
there are many many more toes than you
can actually discern by I here because
the symbols are overlapping so when we
talk about these concentrations you do
have to keep in mind that these are
numbers that are scaled up we didn't
collect 200 thousand pieces of plastic
in those two thousand bath tubs of water
the maximum number of pieces that we
collected in any one toe which I think
was somewhere in here was 1,069 and in
general of the toes that contained
plastic most fifty percent of the toes
had less than 20 piece re less than yeah
20 pieces of plastic and that's
equivalent to 11,000 pieces per
kilometer squared so just to kind of
give you a sense of what this figure is
representing so the question is you know
is this a lot of plastic or isn't it
that's one basic question our estimate
and this is a very broad brush estimate
lots of caveats to it but our first
guest estimate the amount of plastic
this represents floating in the ocean is
1,100 tons so if you're starting with an
image of a floating landfill that's
probably not a lot of plastic but if you
consider the fact that plastic never
started in the ocean I still think it's
a fairly disturbing number and it's
obviously a lower bound as well we're
only sampling six crews tracks a year
we're only sampling the surface sea
surface we're only sampling things that
are bigger than a third of a millimeter
in size we have no idea what the
vertical distribution is in the water
column etc so certainly this is a
minimum estimate okay so let's take a
look at the highest distribution of
values so if you notice the
the red and the black symbols are all
concentrated sort of in this region
which I'll call the subtropics and I
think one of the first surprising
results is that if you look along the
coastline you really don't see the
highest values there and that's
surprising because we do is we do assume
that land is one of the big sources of
plastic to the ocean so you might expect
to see high values here decreasing
offshore but in fact we see the opposite
situation if you look at the average
plastic concentration as a function of
latitude and it's tipped on its side
here so we can compare with the map so
this is just one degree averages with a
standard error associated with it that's
what the thin black bar is you see that
really is fairly bell-shaped you see
fairly low concentrations of plastic at
the higher latitudes and then a huge
increase here in the subtropics and then
a decrease down when you get into the
tropics and in fact eighty-three percent
of pieces that we collected were
collected between 22 degrees north and
38 degrees north latitude and that's
roughly the latitude of somewhere in
Cuba up to maybe close to Washington DC
so throughout the rest of the top oh
actually let me back up what we can't
say from this we can say now pretty
robustly what the latitudinal limits are
to this collection of plastic in the
ocean what we can't say is how far east
this this high high concentration area
extends that from this data set so from
here on out I'm going to be referring to
either the accumulations accumulation
zone or the high concentration region
and when I talk about that what I'm
talking about really is this area here
bounded by these latitude ranges so why
is the highest plastic content found
here to talk about this we need to
venture into a little bit of
oceanography which is good because
that's actually what i know about most
this is a figure of a cartoon of the
major surface currents of the ocean and
just going to spend a couple minutes
talking about it in case you're not
familiar with our global ocean currents
first of all you will see a very common
feature in most of the ocean basins and
that is a sort of circulation that
encompass that crosses the entire basin
and it's sort of a circular pattern and
you see that in all of the subtropical
basins here in the north
antik in the North Pacific although it
kind of spans the image here in the
South Atlantic in the south sorry the
South Pacific over here in the Indian
Ocean and you also it's harder to tell
in this projection there are also these
same features these closed circulation
features up in the subtropical oceans in
the North Atlantic and in the North
Pacific although interestingly not in
the southern hemisphere and that is
because this current actually goes
around the glow that's the only current
that entirely travels around the globe
unimpeded so these features these closed
circulation features are termed gyres
and so we have two flavors of jurors we
have subtropical gyre and we have some
polar gyres and what we're going to
focus on are the subtropics so let's
take a look at actual real measurements
of ocean currents rather than a cartoon
image what I'm showing here is one of
the best estimates we have of the
average surface circulation of the ocean
the average currents from
state-of-the-art ocean measurements and
this is a 10-year average so here we
have a global map here the Americas so
we have the Pacific Ocean the Atlantic
Ocean the Indian Ocean the way this
figure is constructed is showing you
these black squiggly lines that are very
hard to make out are showing you the
mean direction of flow and the
arrowheads are actually telling you what
flow that are what direction the flow is
these are called streamlines the colors
are showing you the average speed of the
currents at any given place with red
being the fastest currents let's zoom in
a little bit into the North Atlantic's
and stuffs what we care about for the
purposes of this talk so in the North
Atlantic you can now see these make out
these arrowheads a little bit better you
can make out the same clockwise
circulation the subtropical gyre pattern
and you'll see a common feature this
very fast current going up along the
east coast of the US that's the Gulf
Stream I should point out it's
interesting the fastest currents average
currents you see here are the Gulf
Stream the Florida current the loop
current down here those average speeds
are less than a meter per second so in
general we're not talking about
extremely fast speeds but if you look
now in the subtropical gyre region
you'll notice that these black stream
lines are actually coming together and
sort of dead ending in this area
right here at about 30 degrees north and
this area is termed the subtropical
convergence zone that's because these
currents are converging they're coming
together and you notice in this zone
they're extremely slow sluggish currents
so we're talking about speeds of less
than two centimeters per second so
really this is sort of where the
currents are converging it's very hard
for water or anything drifting with the
water to escape this region again it's
sort of a dead end zone now
interestingly enough you might imagine
this would be a very nice place for
plastic to collect because the
convergence currents are going to act to
bring it together and in fact the
relationship between the current
patterns and the data set is very
striking so what I'm showing here is now
our plastic concentration data mapped in
a slightly different way with an overlay
of contour indicating the 2 centimeter
per second speed from that previous
image so aside from the fact that it
looks like a dog or other animal running
away what this is showing you is this
encompass extremely slow sluggish area
where those currents are converging the
plastic concentration map now is a
spatially average map it's been binned
into half degree latitude longitude bins
and smooth with a filter to give us sort
of a more average picture and again the
color scheme blue is low plastic and red
as high plastic and what you notice is
this running dog really just about
encompasses the area where we find the
highest plastic concentration so again
it's very simple makes sense the
currents are coming together the plastic
is floating passively at the ocean
surface and so it is being brought into
this accumulation zone so we can
actually pretty nicely say that we
understand why the plastic is
accumulating here this is important it's
important to note that this does not
tell us the origin of the debris and it
doesn't tell us how long it has been
there and there have been some modeling
studies which I don't have time to talk
about today that can give us some first
guesses for instance we think that
debris could make its way to the center
of this region from the east coast in
about a couple months so we're talking
actually very fast transit times because
of that Gulf Stream carrying it quickly
along the east coast
and then sort of ending up dumping into
this area so that's not to say all the
debris comes from the east coast but any
you know any kind of floating plastic
you put off shore here will end up here
pretty quickly so again this doesn't
tell us how far east this accumulation
zone and extends but if you look at the
previous picture these sluggish currents
actually do extend pretty much across
the basin so last summer we did go out
on an expedition specifically to ask the
question how far does the highest
concentration of plastic extend across
the Atlantic and this was the plastics
at sea North Atlantic expedition what
I'm showing you here is a map of the
subtropical North Atlantic the blue dots
show you the the the data set up until
last summer so the 6100 net toes and
this shows you the cruise track that was
followed last summer extending east from
Bermuda along 30 degrees north along the
center of that convergence zone and then
zigzagging back to try to survey that
entire region pretty much the western
half of the North Atlantic this is the
mid-atlantic ridge right here which sort
of marks the center of the North
Atlantic Basin and what we found was
pretty much uniformly high plastic it
doesn't ever decrease we in other words
we didn't find the edge of the
accumulation zone so here kind of a
similar figure different color scheme
but plastic concentration where the
highest values are purple and then this
green and pretty much uniformly more
than 10,000 pieces per kilometer squared
whereas in the rest of the basin just
quickly going back to this picture I
forgot to mention the Caribbean by the
way relatively low plastic concentration
similarly up here even where those high
population centers relatively low
plastic concentrations so and you know
in this picture there's really almost no
blue we're finding very high plastic
concentrations extending the length of
the cruise track and in fact we had the
record breaker more than 23,000 pieces
of plastic in a single net tow so those
people were picking plastic for two days
and in fact at some point cut it off and
just had to estimate how much was in the
net so there's no indication that that
is decreasing unfortunately it didn't
answer our question we need to go out
there again and keep going
across the basin if you're interested in
learning about the expedition we do it
did have a website that discuss daily
science results there are photos and
videos from see it was an outreach tool
so if you're interested I encourage you
to visit that website okay so what do we
know about other oceans just briefly
what I'm going to show you is a video of
some numerical model results this is a
numerical model that basically was
constructed to have artificial plastic
pieces seeded uniformly across the world
ocean and then the ocean was turned on
and the surface karen's currents were
allowed to carry it where they may and
that evolution was observed for ten
years and so the idea was to try to
understand where globally these
accumulation zones might be so here we
have this image and I just think it's
pretty powerful image you notice it
started out all blue so that was the
uniformly high concentration and over
time you see that this artificial debris
moves away from the equator that's
because the currents are diverging
they're carrying carrying material away
sorry this repeats so you see this this
diversion so growing where there's no
debris and then you can see in these
subtropical gyre regions the North
Atlantic like we've talked about but
also the North Pacific in the so-called
North Pacific Garbage Patch there are
also these accumulation zones and the
other subtropical gyre Xin the southern
basins and also in the Indian Ocean so
right now there are some expeditions
that are going out for the first time to
try to measure these areas to see if
there is in fact floating plastic debris
there and and so far all indications are
yes but we don't know you know again
this is this this model is assuming a
uniformly high concentration at the
start obviously the sources of plastic
to the ocean are varied I mean we can't
assume that this was the initial
condition for our real ocean so while
these the mechanisms exist we really
have no idea how much debris we will
find in any of these places ok I'm going
to shift gears a little bit and start
talking you talk quickly about the
trends in plastic concentration that we
have observed over the
time period of our data sets so what I'm
showing you here is annually average
plastic concentration in that
accumulation zone so in that 20 22 38
degrees north latitude range as a
function of time over the course of our
data set the 22 year time period and the
black lines again are the standard error
associated with that and first thing you
notice is well gee there's a lot of up
and down there's just a lot of
variability and in fact that has been a
little bit of a beast we have worked
long and hard to try to get a decent
picture from that because it is highly
variable and if you look even on the if
you look you know net total net tose
that stations that are about 30 or 50
miles apart you can get a huge whopping
amount of plastic in one and very little
in the next so there's just a lot of
spatial variability and this is telling
us there's also a lot of temporal
variability in the record and in fact if
you fit a trend line it's flat with an
r-squared of 0 so we are observing no
trend in plastic accumulation in the
Atlantic Ocean and this was surprising
to us given the drastic increase in
global production of plastic over this
time period so the question really is
all right why do we not see a trend so
we have to think about the sources of
plastic to the ocean we also have to
think about how plastic is being removed
from the surface of the ocean and again
to remind you we're talking about
plastic larger than a third of a
millimeter in size floating at the sea
surface this is not a picture of exact
of entirely what is in the ocean but in
that particular data set so what is
acting to potentially remove plastic
from the surface of the ocean so first
let's talk about the source we thought
well you know we we need some kind of
number about how much plastic might be
entering the ocean and because the
sources are so dispersed widespread and
not well quantified we couldn't we
couldn't estimate it directly so instead
we had to look at proxy record which is
provided by the Environmental Protection
Agency they have reports of you know
municipal solid waste in the United
States over back since nineteen sixty so
what I'm showing here is a time series
of plastic waste generation how much
waste is generated and then how much
waste is discarded and the difference
between these is the amount that was
actually recycled
recycling is being taken into account
into this curve so plastic waste
discards were greatly increasing over
this time period so given this we feel
like it is a reasonable assumption to
say that the amount of plastic entering
the ocean over that time period
increased it is important to note also
this curve doesn't take into a cab
dumping from ships it also doesn't take
into account anything about those resin
pellets nonetheless we are assuming it's
increasing so we have to investigate
other aspects of the trend first could
there be a sampling bias or variability
to surface ocean currents these are
processed questions did we does our
figure actually represent what we think
it does and we we think it does so I'm
not going to go into those details we
thought about the source a little more
carefully thought well maybe even though
more plastic as being being and entered
into the waste stream maybe it's not the
kind that floats and actually the EPA
does break this down by material and so
we looked at the curve of buoyant resins
the floating plastics and in fact those
increased by about twenty-five percent
over the time period so again we're
pretty convinced the amount of plastic
that floats entering the ocean has
increased so then we had to look at
marine removal Beckett mechanisms what
might be taking it away we know that
plastic pieces probably get to be
smaller than a third of a millimeter and
we're not measuring them but we don't
know how small I get or how or how much
is out there sedimentation we know that
there can be those biofilms bear on the
plastics other interesting organisms
grow on the plastic could make them
dense enough that they have to sink away
from the ocean they sink away from the
ocean surface again to where we can't
measure them no estimate no good
quantification of that short deposition
we know that plastic is washing up on
shore as well as being removed from
shore and we do have records from East
Coast beaches which show that it's
highly variable seasonally dependent
depends on the beach so this doesn't
answer our question and then finally we
know that organisms of various at
various parts of the trophic level are
eating plastic but we don't know who
eats it we don't know what happens after
it's eaten we don't know what happens
after the organism dies so really these
are these are things that can remove it
but we have no idea how the
any of those terms are very briefly we
did find one really important trend in
our data set and that's in those resin
pellets so we did distinguish those when
picking them out the students pellets
versus pieces and over the entire region
we did see a statistically significant
decrease in pellet concentration over
time and we believe this is in direct
response to plastic industries response
to an EPA study implementing measures to
reduce the the spillage of pellet
transport and handling the spillage and
the transport and handling processes so
we think that this actually is a really
nice demonstration of changing changing
habits onshore that are then being
observed in the ocean and could probably
be a model study ok wrapping up quickly
because we're getting in here and
there's a class outstanding questions
pretty much all of them are still
outstanding how much plastic is in the
ocean where is it located we can say
generally we know where to look for it
now but we again because of the spatial
variability we haven't looked in
vertically in the water column this is
still very much an open question
although the question is a bit more
refined what is the fate of plastic
marine debris I just listed a number of
mechanisms that may be taking it away
from the surface but we don't know what
happens to it there or in other parts of
the ocean and what are the biological
and chemical implications we still just
don't know so in summary essays plastic
marine debris dataset is the longest and
most extensive record of plastic marine
debris in any ocean and I think these
data provide a really important baseline
again undergraduates mostly responsible
for this hope I've convinced you the
plastic debris does accumulate in the
subtropical convergence zone of the
Western North Atlantic and likely and
other ocean basins although please don't
call it a garbage patch and then despite
a likely increase in source input we do
not observe a trend in the amount of
debris in the North Atlantic and we
don't know why yet we don't know where
it's going this is the case of the
missing debris and then finally just to
wrap it up our garbage patch is a
problem you might think let's just clean
it up what's the big deal I think you
know after looking at what these pieces
look like it's just not feasible and we
can talk about why you might also think
well maybe these new biopolymers will
prevent the problem from getting worse
and just a very strong word of warning
about when you see the labeled
biodegradable on
kind of product you don't know what that
means some of these products are in fact
biodegradable but only in very specific
environmental facilities we have no idea
what happens to the marine environment
so in my opinion the real solution is
controlling the source of debris and
that means all of you perhaps reducing
the amount of packaging that you consume
and also from the manufacturers side of
things but also then reusing and
recycling what you do use and I guess
I'll leave it there just to acknowledge
acknowledgments of my co-authors and
also the the work of the students that
really do the bulk of the work and if
anybody is interested there are reprints
of the article outside and also
information about SCA and I'm also happy
to you know chat with you afterwards
thanks very much